-Here with the TV debut of their
new single, "Skin of My Teeth,"
once again, Demi Lovato!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Demi leaves rehab again ♪
♪ When is this gonna end? ♪
♪ Sounds like the voice
in my head ♪
♪ I can't believe I'm not dead ♪
♪ I'm alive by the skin
of my teeth ♪
♪ I survived but it got harder
to breathe ♪
♪ Askin' why doesn't
make it easier ♪
♪ Go easier on me ♪
♪ God help me,
I just want to be free ♪
♪ But I can't
'cause it's a disease ♪
♪ I'm alive by the skin of my ♪
♪♪
♪ Whoo-hoo, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ The reaper knocks on my door ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm addicted to more ♪
♪ I don't need you
to keep score ♪
♪ When I'm the one
who's at war ♪
♪ I'm alive by the skin
of my teeth ♪
♪ I survived but it got harder
to breathe ♪
♪ Askin' why doesn't
make it easier ♪
♪ Go easier on me ♪
♪ God help me,
I just want to be free ♪
♪ But I can't
'cause it's a disease ♪
♪ I'm alive by the skin of ♪
♪ I'm just tryin' to keep
my head above water ♪
♪ I'm your son
and I'm your daughter ♪
♪ I'm your mother,
I'm your father ♪
♪ I'm just a product of the ♪
♪ I'm just tryin' to keep
my head above water ♪
♪ I'm your son
and I'm your daughter ♪
♪ I'm your mother,
I'm your father ♪
♪ I'm aliiiive ♪
♪ I'm alive by the skin
of my teeth ♪
♪ Won't you try and have some
mercy on me? ♪
♪ Askin' why
doesn't make it easier ♪
♪ Go easier on me ♪
♪ God help me,
I just want to be free ♪
♪ But I can't
'cause it's a disease ♪
♪ I'm alive by the skin of my ♪
♪♪
♪ Whoo-hoo, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ I'm alive by ♪
♪ By the skin of my teeth ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]